[Musique]
une série de conférences intitulé
regards d'ici et d'ailleurs sur
l'engagisme à la réunion s'est déroulée
dans l'hémicycle du département aux
archives et à l'université de la réunion
c'est la suite de ce grand chantier
patrimonial et mémorielles liés à la
création d'un conseil scientifique
adossé au lazaret de la grande chaloupe
c'est de mettre en relation des gens qui
viennent d'ailleurs donc du mozambique
de madagascar les comores de l'inde avec
les chercheurs locaux et échanger sur
cette question de l'engagisme confrontés
les regards sur ce qui se passe un rayon
cette confrontation devrait permettre
justement de passer au delà de la
question des sources qui est le thème
central de notre blog c'est à dire
comment aller plus loin et retrouver la
trace de ses ancêtres faire ce voyage
comme beaucoup d'entre nous cherche
refaire ce voyage qui permet de
retrouver un ancêtre avait traversé
l'océan et retrouver les pays d'origine
parmi les intervenants jean barbier
conservateur en chef du musée historique
de villèle
l'objectif de ces journées d'étude c'est
effectivement de déjà de faire un
recensement de toutes les sources
puisque la thématique abandonné source
dans l'histoire et de d'essayer à court
terme effectivement de partager le
résultat des recherches des chercheurs
qui ont été conviés à ces journées
d'étude donc une de nos missions ce sera
effectivement après les journées d'étude
de pouvoir trouver le moyen de
communiquer le résultat de ses
recherches depuis plusieurs années le
conseil départemental de la réunion
s'est engagé dans la valorisation du
site de la grande chaloupe avec
notamment les chantiers de restauration
d'el azhar et on veut valoriser les
ruines valoriser l'histoire est
respectée aussi le temps qui passe et
qui prend sur ses ruines parce que on va
restaurer ces ruines mais avec cette
emprise de la nature et de temples et du
temps qui passe et un travail minutieux
d'orfèvre qui fait que lorsqu'on vient
et lorsqu'on viendra au lazaret puisque
le chantier n'est pas terminé on aura
une autre appréhension de l'histoire et
on va être dans un atmosphère qui va
laisser toute la place à notre
imagination
trois jours de colloque qui se sont
achevés avec la journée commémorative à
la mémoire des engagés le 11 novembre
lazaret de la grande chaloupe
[Musique]